DEIGN.
>> Katie: CALIFORNIA CHEF IS
APOLOGIZING FOR GETTING
BURNED SAYING HE WOULDN'T
SERVE CUSTOMERS WHO COME IN
WEARING MAGA HAT.
HE ALSO COMPARED THE HAT TO
A SWASTIKA AND WHITE HOOD.
CNN HOSTS TALKING ABOUT THIS
ISSUE LAST NIGHT AFTER
CLAIMING THEY DON'T SUPPORT
THESE TYPES OF BANS THEY
THEN SAID THIS.
>> YOU CAN REFUSE SERVICE.
NO SHIRT, NO SHOES, NO
SERVICE.
HOW IS THAT THIS ANY
DIFFERENT THAN THE BAKER
WITH THE CAKE.
THAT WAS ABOUT REFUSING
SERVICE TO A GROUP OF PEOPLE
THAT SHOULD BE A PROTECTED
CLASS.
AND UNLESS YOU COULD ARGUE
THAT TRUMP SUPPORTERS SHOULD
BE A PROTECTED CLASS I DON'T
THINK YOU HAVE MUCH OF AN
ARGUMENT ON THAT.
I DON'T WANT TO FALL INTO
THE TRAP OF UNDER SELLING
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE
TRIGGER OF THE EXPRESSION TO
PEOPLE.
>> YOUR CLOTHING TELLS A
STORY ABOUT WHO YOU ARE WHAT
YOU THINK ABOUT AND WHAT YOU
REPRESENT.
THAT HAT MEANS EVERYTHING
FROM I WOULD SAY THE
BEGINNING OF THE CAMPAIGN
MAYBE THAT HAT MEANS THE
BIRTHERISM TO PEOPLE.
MAYBE IT MEANS MEXICANS ARE
RAPISTISTS TO PEOPLE.
>> Katie: OR MAYBE IT MEANS
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN,
GREG.
>> Greg: IT'S LIKE THEY
SHARE ONE BRAIN.
REALLY IS SWEET.
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS
BEFORE.
IT'S NOT REALLY ABOUT A HAT.
IT'S ABOUT THE EXPANSION OF
A TARGET BY THE MEDIA.
IT IS THE MEDIA'S RESPONSE
RESPONSIBILITY.
IT'S NO LONGER ABOUT TRUMP
AND NO LONGER ABOUT VOTING
FOR TRUMP.
BECAUSE, IF YOU ARE NOT PART
OF THE RESISTANCE THAT'S
ENABLING.
YOU ARE JUST LIKE A STORM
TROOPER YOU ARE LIKE A NAZI.
THE THING IS IT'S NOT ABOUT
TRUMP.
IT'S NOT ABOUT A HAT.
IT'S NOT ABOUT VOTING
ANYMORE.
IT'S ABOUT ANY KIND OF
EXTENSION TO TRUMP.
SO THEY HAVE WIDENED THE
TARGET NOW SO THAT IT'S A
CULTURAL WITCH-HUNT.
YOU KEEP SHAKING YOUR HEAD,
JUAN.
WE HAVE SO MANY EXAMPLES OF
THIS CULTURAL WITCH-HUNT FOR
ANYBODY AND SANCTIONED BY
PEOPLE LIKE LEMON WHO SAY
OKAY IF YOU ARE NOT PART OF
OUR GROUP YOU ARE EEL.
THIS IS REALLY BAD
DEMONIZING HALF THE COUNTRY.
>> Juan: THE MAGA HATS FOR A
LOT OF PEOPLE SAY IF YOU ARE
NOT PART OF OUR GROUP YOU
ARE EVIL.
IT IS A PROVOCATIVE
STATEMENT.
ON THE FACE OF IT PIECE OF
CLOTHING.
THE FACT THAT I DO IT AS A
PROVOCATIVE PIECE OF
CLOTHING.
>> Greg: WHY DO YOU DO THAT?
>> Juan: I THINK DON LIMO
AND CUOMO WERE ON TARGET.
>> Greg: GET THE IDEA?
>> Juan: HOW ABOUT DAVID
DUKE WEARING IT?
HOW ABOUT CAESAR SHOOTING
PEOPLE RIDING ON THE TRUMP
TRUCK HOLDING A MAGA HAT.
>> Greg: NO MORE ORANGE
JUICE?
I CAN'T DRINK ORANGE JUICE
BECAUSE RACIST DRINK ORANGE
JUICE.
>> Juan: THEY MADE A GOOD
POINT IT'S A PROTECTED CLASS
MATTER OF DISCRIMINATION.
PROTECTED CLASS IS MY
GENDER, MY SEX, MY
DISABILITY.
IT'S NOT MY POLITICAL
BELIEF.
>> Greg: I'M OKAY WITH THE
CHEF HE IS PAYING HIS PRICE.
THAT'S THE WAY THE MARKET
SHOULD WORK.
IF YOU MAKE A DECISION, THEN
YOU PAY THE PRICE.
>> Juan: IT'S A FREE MARKET
DECISION.
LIKE NIKE SAYING WE ARE
BACKING COLIN KAEPERNICK
THEY MADE A DECISION.
THIS GUY APOLOGIZED BY THE
WAY.
HE APOLOGIZED TO THE PEOPLE
WHO WORK AT THE RESTAURANT
AND HIS CO-INVESTORS BECAUSE
IT MIGHT CAUSE SOMEONE NOT
TO COME TO THE RESTAURANT HE
DIDN'T SAY MAGA HATS ARE --
>> Katie: HE CAN DO WHAT HE
WANTS IT'S A PRIVATE
BUSINESS.
HE DIDN'T REALLY APOLOGIZE
HE THEN WENT ON TO SAY IN
HIS APOLOGY THAT THE HAT
SYMBOLIZES HATE, ANGER AND
VIOLENCE LIKE OWN IT OR NOT.
>> Jesse: IF KANYE CAME IN
ROCKING THE HAT I WONDER IF
HE WOULD SERVE KANYE WEST.
I THINK HE WOULD.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
BAKER DEAL.
THE BAKER WAS A CHRISTIAN
WHEN YOU ARE ASKED TO BAKE A
GAY WEDDING CAKE AND ASKED
TO SAY GOD BLESS DICK AND
JOHN AND THERE IS TWO GUYS
IN THE MIDDLE AND HE IS
ARGUING HE IS COMPLICIT IN
MAKING A CAKE THAT DOESN'T
REPRESENT YOUR CHRISTIAN
VALUES.
IF YOU ARE JUST SERVING
BURGERS AND FRIES.
YOU ARE NOT PARTICIPATING.
>> Katie: NOT FORCING THE
CHEF TO WEAR A MAGA HAT.
>> Jesse: TOTALLY DIFFERENT
ANALOGY.
SOMEONE WITH THE AUTHORITY
ON SWEEPING GENERALIZATIONS.
SOMETHING CNN IS DOING TO
SAY THIS HAT REPRESENTS THIS
SO SO MANY PEOPLE PERMISSION
TO MAKE AN ANALOGY?
>> Greg: I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
IT IF YOU HAVE A NEW ENGLAND
PATRIOTS HAT.
TO SOME PEOPLE THAT MIGHT
REPRESENT CHEATING AND SPY
GATE AND DOUBLE HOMICIDE
HERNANDEZ.
>> Katie: BY SOME PEOPLE HE
MEANS HIM.
>> Jesse: TO OTHER PEOPLE
THAT COULD JUST MEAN THE
PATRIOTS AND WINNING.
SO I THINK WHEN THIS COUNTRY
TELLS YOU DON'T WEAR THIS
CLOTHING, DRIVE THIS CAR,
STOP SAYING MERRY CHRISTMAS,
BABY IT'S COLD OUTSIDE IS
ABOUT RAPE.
THIS IS THE REASON DONALD
TRUMP BECAME ELECTED WE ARE
SO SICK OF PEOPLE TELLING
THEM WHAT TO DO HOW TO THINK
AND WHAT TO SAY.
>> Katie: DANA, THE MEDIA
CONTINUES TO ALLOW THESE
COMPARISONS TO FLY WITHOUT
ANY CONTEXT.
THEY CONTINUE TO SAY THAT IT
REPRESENTS A KKK HOOD
WITHOUT CONTEXT OF WHAT THE
KKK ACTUALLY DID AND SAYING
MAGA HAT IS EQUAL TO THAT.
I FEEL LIKE THAT DOWN PLAYS
THE SEVERITY OF THECA.
KKK WAS AND SOMETHING WE
HAVE ERADICATED FROM THIS
COUNTRY AND NOT SOMETHING
THAT WE CONDONE.
>> Greg: EXCEPT FOR
YEARBOOKS.
>> Katie: EXCEPT FOR
YEARBOOKS FOR DEMOCRATS.
>> Dana: ALSO ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF WHY GROWN PEOPLE
SHOULD GET OFF TWITTER.
AND IF YOU THINK HE IS GOING
TO HAVE TO APOLOGIZE TO YOUR
PARTNERS.
TWITTER IS DIMINISHING
PEOPLE'S LIVES.
GET OFF.
>> Juan: ALL COMMIT AND GET
OFF IT THEN.
>> Juan: IT'S A GOOD IDEA.
>> Greg: KILL THE BUSINESS.
THEY ARE USING US.
WE ARE NOT GETTING PAID TO
TWEET.
>> Jesse: HOW AM I GOING TO
PROMOTE MY SHOW.